(bass drum thumps)
- I spend no time on the
cheering or the boos.
I spend on executing so
that when it goes to 000,
I can say I was right.
(audience member hoots)
(exciting music)
(man shouting)
You've got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
What is up, Singapore?
Thank you.
What up!
Please sit, thank you.
Couple things.
I know that it's been a long day
and so what I wanna do is bring
as much value as possible.
We're gonna try to do a bunch of Q and A
which I'm excited about.
I'm gonna set up some framework
for where I'm coming
with my current thoughts
on entrepreneurship, marketing,
certain things I'm seeing.
But, most importantly,
I definitely am excited
to open up the Q and A session
a little bit earlier than we had planned
because I think that's where
most of the value comes from.
I think the thing that
I wanna start off with
this afternoon, this evening,
is putting into context
something that's been running
through my mind a lot lately
which is perspective.
What's really fascinating
to me is something
that's emerged as almost
difficult to fully understand
which is it's unbelievable
that life is as basic
as how do you see it.
For me, I've been saying a lot lately
and have always and to a
lot of people close to me
a statement that says you
find what you're looking for.
If you're looking for negativity,
it's very easy to find.
If you're looking for positivity,
If you think it's going to be successful,
you start to see signals
that lead to that.
And if you think it's gonna
fail, you'll see that.
If you're cynical and a
pessimist, that's what you see.
If you're optimistic and positive,
that's what you're gonna see.
And really, the vulnerability
to the way I roll, which is
optimistic and positivity,
is you could become delusional.
It's not practical.
You think you can just
dream it into success.
You don't understand the requirements
and the costs and the sacrifices
that are needed to actually get somewhere.
I think the biggest thing
that I've been spending time on lately
from a perspective standpoint
is we are all now affected
by the last 10 to 15
years of entrepreneurship
and when we look at stories like Facebook
or WeChat or Uber or Weibo,
we see these extreme monstrous successes
and they cloud the fact
that for the 15 companies
that actually got to billions in revenue
and actually run actual businesses
not predicated on venture capital,
there's 80 trillion
businesses that didn't.
We spend all our time fascinated
on these enormous victories
without spending our time on practicality.
And so, for me, what I
really wanted to establish
in this talk today is a couple things.
One, the macro-perspective
I believe that I'm seeing
in people that are succeeding.
And when I say succeeding,
I think an important part of perspective
in today's day and age
is I believe that the
way we define success
is fundamentally broken in human society.
We are spending way too much money,
way too much time on
putting money on a pedestal
and way little amount of time and energy
into putting happiness on a pedestal.
The amount of millionaires,
people that make millions,
10 millions, hundreds of
millions of dollars a year
that I know that are
disproportionately unhappy
is staggering.
And I really, really, really am passionate
about getting a conversation
into the ecosystem
of, like, why are you here?
Why are you actually here today?
What are you trying to accomplish?
Do you have enough self-awareness
and understanding about yourself
to know what you're trying to achieve?
Because I promise you,
over this last decade,
interacting with people at
scale, publicly and privately,
what's very obvious to me
is that an enormous amount of people
are trying to get success
to put make-up around
their actual insecurities.
They're spending all their
time trying to make money
to hide what's actually happening.
They're trying to prove
something to somebody else,
not to themselves.
And no level of you finding
a path to making money
is going to solve that issue.
And so, I think that we're living
through a very, very
remarkable time in our society
where this device
can really be an unlock to
an enormous amount of things
but I don't think people actually
know where they're going.
And that's something that I've become
unbelievably fascinated with.
One of the biggest
reasons I've found myself
talking more about mindset and perspective
and things of that nature
was I spend every day putting out content
that shows people exactly what to do
with their personal
brand or their business
to be successful,
and yet people don't take advantage
of the current state of the internet
to achieve their business goals.
After a while, I started
to have to ask myself,
"Why are people not doing that?"
And I didn't go into the lazy talk
of thinking people are lazy
or things of that nature.
It all led to one big game of insecurity.
The reason a lot of people here
don't post every single day
is 'cause they're worried
about the judgment
in the comments section of what they post.
And so, before I get into the details
of what I wanna talk to you about
from a YouTube or a Facebook or a Twitter
or a podcast or running
ads, before any of that,
I can give you every single
tactic that is underpriced.
But if you don't have a
foundational understanding
of what you like to do and why,
it's impossible for you to be successful
because we now live in a world
where somebody will outwork you
and take your piece.
There's abundance and
there's plenty for everybody
but what has become very clear to me
is nobody beats the person
that loves what they're
doing and is good at it
because they're just always doing it.
What became obvious to
me about entrepreneurship
is I always did it even
when it wasn't cool
or in the air like it is now.
What's obvious to me today
is there are so many people
that want to be entrepreneurs
'cause it is cool today
and it's actually not who they should be.
The amount of people in
this attendance today
who want to be entrepreneurs
or start companies
who would be far more
successful financially
and happy being the
number four in a company
run by an actual
entrepreneur is staggering.
That's not something that anybody in here
who's delusional wants to hear.
But it is still absolutely the truth.
Because anytime a pendulum swings,
it swings too far the other way.
Only 15 years ago, not going to college
was not even in the cards,
especially not in
(chuckling) Southeast Asia.
And yet now, people are debating that
and aspiring to that at scale
even if it has nothing to do
with who they actually are.
They've just created the perception
that starting your own company
and being an entrepreneur
is the right or cool
or awesome thing to do.
The only reason you should
be at this conference at all
is for you to find a path
to being content and happy,
not to make an arbitrary amount of money.
I wanna make a million,
I wanna make 10 million,
I wanna make, arbitrary.
You're just picking a fucking
number out of your ass.
What you need to be doing, thanks, Mom,
what you need to be doing,
(audience chuckling)
what you need to be doing is deploying
the greatest game of self-awareness
anybody has ever done.
This is one big game of self-awareness.
I don't want you to do what I do.
I was a five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10-year-old child
who'd rather go and shovel
snow and wash people's car
and sell lemonade than
go outside and play.
I was a kid who never
opened up a single textbook
from fourth grade until 12th grade.
That is not necessarily who you are.
And so, I start this conversation,
you know, (chuckling) I
flew a long way to come here
to create a very important conversation,
far more important than me telling you
that Instagram ads and
Stories are so underpriced
in all of Southeast Asia
that if you start buying
ads on Instagram stories
for $2 and $3 a CPM swipe-up ads
to a direct link to whatever
you do, whatever you sell,
as important as that tactic is,
as important as it would be
for all of you to leave this conference,
go home, google how do I write,
how do I run Instagram Story Ads,
as much as it would
matter for me to tell you
that if you target a
certain group of people
then make the content for that group
then run $50 worth of ads
then look at the quant data then adjust it
and keep adjusting until
your cost of acquisition
is worth your lifetime value,
as important as that is,
as basic, as basic as
that is and important
and would work for 75% of this audience
to achieve whatever you want,
that tactic is bullshit
if the only thing you're
trying to do is make money.
'Cause it is not sustainable.
And so, look.
I'm really, really hopeful
that my opening 10 minutes here
sets the tone to what
I'm trying to achieve
which is, as I continue to evolve
and travel and do all this stuff,
the same themes are coming
up over and over and over.
I wanna remind everybody here,
we've lived through a decade now
of economic growth and
prosperity across the world.
We are in a bubble.
There's so much money and
opportunity in the system
that this is not sustainable.
There will be a day of reckoning
just like there was in 2007-8,
just like there was one in 2001 and '95.
And for people that have lived
through some down cycles,
you think it's hard now.
When all the money dries
up, it gets real hard.
Let me say it very basically.
If you don't have a
successful company right now
and you've been operating
for the last two years,
you suck.
And I mean that.
And I'm not saying that,
I'm not trying to razz,
I'm not trying to come hard.
I need you to understand.
How many people here run a company
or an entrepreneur start-up?
Just raise your hands.
Raise it high.
I need you to understand
if you're running a company
right now in the globe,
this is the easiest time
in the history of humans
to run a company.
So, if you're not doing well,
you need to really recognize that.
(chuckling) You do.
And so, I'm unbelievably optimistic
because this thing is that special.
I'm this optimistic
because the little
piece of business advice
in practical terms that I
slipped in five minutes ago,
I'm gonna say it one
more time nice and slow,
it will legitimately work
for 80% of this audience.
Instagram Story Ads in
all of Southeast Asia,
except in Japan and China
where other platforms
dominate, not Instagram,
will work for your business.
But what you have to figure out
is your targeting and your creative.
The biggest reason people don't succeed
in running ads on social
networks and platforms
is 'cause they don't make enough content.
And they don't make the content
for the audience they're trying to reach.
They make one piece of content
and try to reach everybody.
Contextual creative at scale is the game.
It's really interesting.
I've been really watching
a lot of businesses
and entrepreneurs navigate
the last year or so
and what's really become interesting to me
is the themes that play over
and over and over again.
In its most basic, the biggest thing
that everybody has to leave here with
is the following thing.
The only thing that you
should spend all your time on
to really disproportionately
grow your business
is to figure out where the customer
that you're trying to reach
spends all of their time.
Once you understand where
they spend all of their time,
all you should ever do
is try to figure out
how your brand, your
personal brand, your business
can penetrate that attention
in the form of organic content
or in the form of ads.
It's that basic.
When I look at the data in Singapore
and I don't know if some of you heard
but VaynerMedia is opening an office here
in a couple of months,
the reason we're coming
to the entire region
is that everything that I've used
to build up my personal brand,
to build business results,
all of that works better in this market
than it even does in
Europe and in the U.S.
where we've been doing that marketing.
For me, the quicker everybody here
can become a media company,
the quicker they can become successful.
The quicker you think of
yourself not as a salesperson
but as somebody who produces content
that provides value to the end user,
the quicker you will get results.
The reason most people struggle
with social media marketing
or digital marketing
or marketing or communications
is because they're salespeople,
they're not marketers.
The difference is very simple.
When you look, and I did, a lot
of people tagged this event,
tweeted at me, so I looked at
20 or 30 of the accounts here
over the last 12 hours,
when I look at your accounts,
everything is selfish.
Everything is about what you're selling,
what you want them to do for you.
All the content is
there to get more likes,
to get more followers, for
somebody to buy your product,
go into your funnel, create
a capture of data at the top
so you can remarket to it.
It's 100% selfish.
That is exactly what all of you don't want
in your normal life from the
other people you consume,
but it's exactly what the
far majority of people
are doing with their own
content for their own business.
This is one big game of being over-selfish
instead of being selfless.
One of the reasons the
biggest book I ever wrote
was called "Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook"
was it helped so many people understand
a different framework
which is you have to give,
you have to give, you have to give,
and then you can ask for something.
The problem is when
people ask, they expect.
The disproportionate reason
that I see businesses be successful
and definitely personalities be successful
are the ones that give without expectation
because the content, when they give,
is not loaded with intent to be selfish.
There's a lot of people that
give but it's a half-give.
It's actually an ask disguised as a give.
What's happened is there's so much content
now on the internet, there's
so much supply of information,
as remarkable as these channels are,
what's amazing is that every
one of you can be in it,
the problem is every
one of you can be in it.
So, what happens is the
cream rises to the top.
What's happening is it's
very hard to break through
if you're being selfish
because somebody else is being selfless.
This is how life has always been.
The maturity has now hit this device.
Couple things I wanna talk
about before I go into Q and A.
Number one, you have to figure out,
as a person, as a business,
how you communicate to the world.
There are three ways:
written word, audio, and video.
Too many people are trying to do video
when they're not capable of it.
Too many people are not realizing
written word is remarkable
and they're getting caught up in pictures
because Instagram's popping.
So, the number one thing that
would really matter to me
as a data point is the following.
I believe the more
content that you put out,
the more likely you'll be successful.
I believe that you have
to reverse-engineer
the end consumer,
that you have to bring
as much valuable content
to them as possible.
I think that you also
need to eliminate friction
between your message and the customer.
What that means is you
have to show up everywhere
to the best of your ability
in the way they wanna consume it.
How many people here listen to my podcast?
Raise your hands.
(audience member hoots)
Thank you.
Real quick, hold them up real quick.
Watch this, everybody
look around, keep it up.
Listen to my podcast.
Now, keep it up, keep it up.
I wanna show everybody something.
If you did not listen to
my podcast two years ago,
put your hand down.
What everybody just saw,
thank you very much,
what everybody just saw
is not only the rise in my popularity,
you are seeing the rise
of audio consumption.
How many people here now
listen to more podcasts
than they did three years ago?
Raise your hands.
Look.
How many people now when
they watch videos online
actually don't even watch the video,
they just put it down and just listen?
This is what I spend all my time on.
I didn't go all in on my
podcast for my health.
I went in all in on my podcast
because I knew that you started
listening to more audio,
not read as much, not watch as much video.
At the same token,
probably the best and
biggest piece of advice
that I can give this audience today
is a really interesting one.
When I wrote my last book, "Crushing It!",
I did not even talk about LinkedIn.
Wasn't even part of my book.
As I stand here today, as
somebody who spends all his time
trying to figure out where
the underpriced attention is,
the number one place that's emerged for me
in the last three to six
months has been LinkedIn.
How many people here are
producing content for LinkedIn?
Raise your hand.
Nice.
Solid but an extremely low
percentage of this audience.
If I can leave you
with another tactical
piece of advice today,
it is for you to get very
serious about LinkedIn.
It is grossly underpriced
attention, it's organic,
and the amount of reach it's getting,
even for people in here
who've never posted once,
is remarkable.
LinkedIn, written or audio
or video content in a
post, remarkable growth.
It reminds me of Facebook in 2012.
And I believe a lot of you,
whether you're B2B or B2C,
or, how many people here have a job?
Raise your hand.
Job.
How many people would
like to leave their job
and start their own business?
Higher.
The number one tactic, I believe,
that can make 30% of the
hands that just went up
have a practical transition
from going from a job to
having their own business
is strictly just blogging on LinkedIn
on a daily basis around
opinions and thoughts they have
in the business that
they're in or want to be in.
Simple as that.
The game is based on action.
And for me, the action
that is most required
is to be a content producer.
I genuinely believe
that no matter what your
ambition is in this room,
that if you are not producing
written word, audio, or video
for the internet on a daily basis,
you will limit your upside
and you will become
vulnerable to competitors
that are trying to reach
the same audience you are.
This is a very important mindset
because what's remarkable about this
is what I'm actually
saying is everybody in here
needs to think more like a
publisher in a media company
than what they actually do for a living.
Are you a lawyer?
Cool, I also want you to
write content every day.
Are you a financial advisor?
Awesome, I want you to
write content every day.
Are you a salesperson?
Are you a tech SAS founder?
Are you this, that, the other thing?
The gateway to everybody's ambition
is content because communication
is the foundational aspect
of how everybody makes every decision.
The reason there's so much scrutiny
on big tech companies all over the world
is because our attention is now there
and that is changing our
opinions about everything.
There's a reason that when
there's a coup in a country,
they go after the newspaper,
radio, and television first.
Even before they raid the
palace, they go for the media
'cause the media dictates how you think.
A scary amount of every
opinion in your head
was put there by the content you consumed,
by the content that your parents consumed
and then put into your head.
Your ability to put
content into the ecosystem
and create the outcome that you aspire to
is the fundamental variable.
This computer in my hand is more powerful
than the computer that Ronald Reagan had
running America only 30, 40 years ago.
This is a remarkable shift in our society.
And what's scary to me is how few people
actually go all in and
take advantage of it.
How many people here consume my content?
There's nothing I've said
that you haven't heard before.
I pound this message every day.
Every day.
I come and I give it onstage
'cause I'm hoping maybe,
'cause we're in person,
you hear it this time.
Or maybe because something
happened yesterday,
you hear it this time.
By the way, I think, especially
in this section first,
if you have questions you
should line up right away
'cause I'm gonna go into Q and A
and then I'll open it
up to everybody else.
If you have questions, you
can go to left and right,
I'll start.
I come here and pound this message
because the reality is
life is remarkably simple.
Everybody overthinks
this stuff dramatically.
You've heard this from me consistently.
This is exactly what is
going on in our society.
I'm just trying to figure
out how I convince you
to start actually making.
I believe that producing
content on the internet
for you or your business
is the equivalent of working
out in the gym every day.
There is no shortcut.
But the results are there
when you put in the work.
I'm trying to figure out why you're not.
That's how I've gotten into insecurity
or keeping up with the Joneses
or why I'm mad at every
goddamn parent in the world.
That's how I got there.
Because there is absolutely
no lack of information
if you consume my content
of LinkedIn or podcast or Instagram.
As a matter of fact, as many of you know,
I yell all the time.
Don't listen to what I'm saying.
Watch what I'm doing.
If I have a vlog, there's a reason.
If I'm posting on
LinkedIn, there's a reason.
If I'm using more Instagram TV
in my main feed on Instagram,
there's a reason.
There's a reason.
And so, I'm just unbelievably passionate
about people figuring out the framework
and then, more importantly,
figuring out why they're
not doing the framework,
and then, more importantly,
what are you trying to accomplish?
That's the question.
Because we have to accomplish happiness.
That has to be the goal.
And if you actually pressured
yourself to be happy
versus pressuring
yourself to be a success,
then you have a totally
different conversation
with yourself.
Then you have a totally
different conversation
with yourself.
And when you start
doing that for yourself,
not to prove it to your
spouse or your siblings
or your parents or the people
you went to school with,
then it gets really good.
It gets really good when
it gets really quiet.
And it's super quiet for me.
I don't hear the claps
and I don't hear the boos.
I just navigate.
I love my process.
I love the pain of being an entrepreneur.
I love that it's lonely.
I love the game.
I just want you to love the game.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
I left a lot of time for Q and A
'cause this is where it's gonna get good.
Let's go, my friend.
What's your name?
- Hey there, Gary.
My name is Nemo Ashong.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, this is my first time
really getting into your world.
- Please.
- That last thing you said
really bothered me.
- Please.
- You love being lonely.
- Yes.
- You asked why am I not taking action?
It's because of the loneliness.
- Let's talk about it.
- Right.
I am someone who is highly relational
and generally speaking
I'm an outlier, a pioneer,
a maverick in anything that I do.
One of the first, one of
the only, or one of a kind.
- Okay.
- And it's very lonely
out there.
So, my question for you is
I wanna be able to build
the next stage of my
business through relationship
and I wanna be able to do it,
I think the question
that's really coming out
is do I have to come off as an expert?
Can I be there with people?
Can I record conversations?
I love document, don't create.
- Yes.
- Can I record conversations with people
that are just real and put it out there?
I want to be able to create this
from a place where it
maintains the relationship
without me having to be an expert.
'Cause honestly, I'm figuring it out, too.
- That's a great question, brother,
and I appreciate you saying it.
The biggest issue in our game right now
is people thinking they have
to fake it till you make it.
Guys, faking till you make it was good
when the internet wasn't around.
Now, people hear the bullshit
coming out of your mouth.
Every single kid that's
ever tried to fake it
until she or he made it
in a meeting with me lost.
'Cause I'm like, "This
person's full of shit.
"They're out."
No, you don't have to be an expert
as long as you don't say you're an expert.
Do you know why I love Q and A?
'Cause I'm not scared.
Because I'm gonna answer
all your fucking questions
and if I don't know the answer,
I'm gonna say, "I don't know."
And that doesn't make me any less capable
of standing on this stage.
In face, it is the reason
I can stand on this stage.
Bro, we grew up in a game
where people fake it till they,
thank you.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
I know the world we all grew up in.
I couldn't believe in social media more,
I couldn't believe in Instagram more,
but Instagram and social media
is where everybody is faking it.
Everybody is a PR agent of themselves.
Everybody's showing the highlights.
Social media is highlights.
That's why I like putting out,
the reason I started DailyVee
was to show you that
it fucking was a grind.
It's not private planes and parties
and fucking Rolexes.
It's fucking work.
And so, yeah, bro, you can
as long as you position it upfront.
That's it.
- Game on.
- You got it.
(audience applauding)
- [Meher] Hi, Gary.
My name is Meher, I'm from India.
I specially flown down
- Thank you.
- especially for you.
- I'm really fascinated the way you are
and the way you project
yourself as being so raw.
One of the things I wanted to ask--
- You mean no fucking suit?
- Yeah, no fucking suit.
(audience chuckling)
I mean, I like the T-shirt,
I like your sneakers,
and I love that
and that's something
(audience member hoots)
which I'm proud of.
I'm starting a digital
marketing agency back in India.
I have two businesses which I created
and I'm now fascinated
about digital marketing.
You're the first person, I
mean, I wanna look up to.
I wanted to ask you
that the world is moving
into doing things by themself.
You know, personal branding
is one of the most important thing people.
Companies are also doing it by themselves.
So, where do you--
- In-housing?
- Yeah, so where do you see,
where do you see the agency
being the support system
for the companies, for smaller
companies, for that matter?
- They're gonna be a
service if they're best.
It's the same thing I just said.
The best part about
social is we can all play.
The worst part is we can all play.
Agencies have to be better
if people are taking things in-house.
- [Meher] Okay.
Could you give some tips about how do we,
you know, how do we get a edge
against the rest of the gang?
Because it's--
- Be great
at what you charge people for.
- [Meher] Okay, yeah. (chuckles)
All right, thanks a lot.
- I mean,
- [Meher] Thank you for that.
- I know it's super simple.
- It is.
- But why the fuck
would I pay you if I could do it myself?
- Right.
- I would pay you
because you're better at it.
- Yeah.
- Why do people hire a cook?
'Cause he or she makes
better food than they can
or because they value time.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- Companies will always
outsource and always in-source things.
It's one big game of value.
- Absolutely.
- You have to explain to me
why I should hire you, right?
- [Meher] Absolutely.
- This is why I, when
I started VaynerMedia,
this is why I worked for free.
When people came up to
me and said, you know--
- [Meher] That was my next question.
You're starting your office in Singapore.
Can I work for you for free?
- Hell yeah.
- Yeah?
As long as it's legal here in Singapore.
I don't know what the
fucking rules are yet.
(Meher chuckling)
But you can send me an email.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Absolutely.
- Thank you, thank you, Gary.
(audience applauding)
- [Audience Member] Well done.
- Hi.
- Hi, Gary, how are you?
Welcome to Singapore.
- Thank you.
- I don't actually have
a question for you.
I'm here because I wanted to
come to thank you personally.
December of 2016, my fiance died
in a motorbike crash overnight
and that meant I had to
take over the company
from being number four
to number one overnight
and I had no idea.
- I'm sorry.
- I panicked.
Also, I found your content
and I had it playing for like six months
every day for like 48 hours,
just there, you know,
blaring through the house.
That positive voice in the
strategies, the advice,
just the guidelines
really helped me a lot.
The company's doing great now, we're fine,
we're growing and we're healthy.
I just wanted to say that
I decided to put your voice
in my head because it's
the closest to my fiance's
except it's in English.
(Gary and audience chuckling)
- [Gary] I'm extremely flattered.
- I came here because I
wanted to say thank you
for all the content that
you've put out there.
It's really great.
It's helped me a lot.
It saved my ass.
You rarely get a chance
to say thank you in person
and I'd like to do that.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- Hey there, Gary.
Matt from Australia.
I'm here with my sister Fiona as well.
Thanks for being a great mentor to us.
Really appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- Mate, I'm curious.
What is the structure of
your team look like for you,
for you to drive your brand?
- My team, yes.
- And what is it gonna look
like in six months' time
and why will it change?
- That's a great question.
Anybody who's looking to go crazy extreme
like I have with content
on an individual basis,
I believe that you need a writer.
I believe that you need a video person
who can not only capture but
can post-produce and publish.
I think you need a designer image.
I believe those three things
are completely required to go all in.
You probably then, when
you have three people
and you're busy, you
probably need an architect
of that three-person team
who can synthesize you
and manage that team.
- So, more than a
project manager actually.
When you say architect,
what does that look like?
- Notice how I used architect
versus project manager?
And by the way, project
management has saved Vayner
so I don't wanna downsize this
but the way I think about it, just to,
and I wouldn't even use project management
'cause I put such a pedestal,
you need somebody who
thinks and makes people do,
not just somebody who
takes direction from you
and makes people do.
'Cause you're busy.
- Yeah.
- You know, I think the big
thing with me that's so crazy
is I know that I'm Gary Vee.
I run a $200-million, thousand-person,
global company every day.
I'm the CEO and COO.
I'm not in an ivory tower.
I'm in my shit.
I'm on HR calls, I'm on... (chuckles)
I figured out this by accident.
All these pieces of content you see
is me living my life and
it's just being captured.
And it's only 10% of my life.
So, you need those people.
I think you need an audio engineer,
similar to the video person,
somebody who can strip the
audio and upload to a podcast
'cause I think a podcast and audio content
is a requirement in six months.
So, look, you're talking about
a four-, five-person team.
- Awesome, thank you.
- You got it.
(audience applauding)
- Hi, Gary, my name--
- How are you?
- I'm good, thank you.
My name is Mary, I'm from Indonesia.
- Pleasure.
- To be honest,
before last year, I don't
know who is Gary Vee.
Never heard of you before.
- I understand.
- But I attended NAC last
year and I listened to you.
I follow your advice,
create contents every day,
and it helps me.
That's how I grew my,
- Thank you.
- I have two millions of followers
in Instagram right now.
That's how I grew my YouTube
with 1.5 million subscriber
which is growing,
so I thank you for that.
- Amazing.
Congratulations.
- My question to you is simple.
You mentioned that create a
video that you care about,
not creating some things that
you think will be popular,
and I totally agree with you.
But at the same time,
you also care so much
about how your audience, your end user,
react on your content.
So, how do you balance between the two?
- By producing every day.
(audience chuckling)
- I mean like--
- Think about it.
- Yeah?
- When you produce
so much content,
today I'm just gonna make
something I wanna make
because tomorrow I'll make something
that you want me to make.
When you're not crippled,
every single piece of content,
you can accomplish everything.
The framework of producing
content every day
gives you permission to do many things
when you look at it over
a year, not over a day.
- Okay.
- If you're crippled
by every piece of content,
well then you have a struggle.
When you realize that you're putting out
53 pieces of content this
week or seven or five,
well all of a sudden you
can do whatever you want
on every individual piece of content
because you don't have to
achieve both contrarian goals
in a single piece of content.
The reason I just put
out that piece of content
is everybody's falling into a trap
of making content that
works on the platform.
Or you know what works
so you keep doing it
but then eventually it becomes
boring for you or for them.
It's very important to
mix up your content.
Otherwise, it becomes stale
either for the person that makes it
or for the audience that consumes it.
It's why I do Q and A.
The first 20 minutes was something
you've heard 5,000 times.
I just believe in it so much
that I will say it every day
for the rest of my fucking life.
It's now when you may hear
something completely different.
That's why I innovated to Q and A,
to put me in a position to
make it more interesting.
- Okay.
- You got it?
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Good.
My name is Vikas and I'm
from a business family
but I was on a spiritual journey.
At the age of 29, I had my own awakening,
sort of like a spiritual breakthrough.
I left my family, I've left
the family business as CEO,
and started from all over again, zero.
I was on a mission to
give wisdom to the world,
to bring wisdom to the world.
- Amazing.
- And I've been doing
that for the last 20 years
to businesses, CEOs, people in general,
- That's amazing.
- teaching people
about mindset and meditation.
Now, I want to grow the brand, grow the,
scale the business to
reach more people globally.
But now, I hear a lot about
that no one wants wisdom
bring it to the business.
Everyone is caring
about making money and--
- Who says that?
(audience chuckling)
- People on platforms like that.
- [Gary] They're wrong.
- What do you advise I do?
- To bring fucking wisdom.
(Vikas and audience laugh)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- What would be the strategy
to take it out of what I'm doing
and bring it to more people
around the world, millions?
- To give the wisdom for free.
- Okay.
- Like me.
(audience applauding)
(Vikas chuckles)
- [Vikas] Got it.
Thank you.
- And you know this.
When you have no money, you want money.
When you get the money,
you want the wisdom.
Everybody's on their own journey.
There is no right answer.
- Right.
- Whether I say it or other
people said something else
which I don't know but I'm sensing,
you need to do you.
Legacy is greater than currency.
- [Vikas] Wow, that's a good line.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
I like it, too.
(Vikas and audience laugh)
- [Vikas] Thank you.
- [Tom] Hi, Gary.
- How are you, my friend?
- Hi, I'm good.
My name is Tom and I'm
a watercolor artist.
In fact, I have a painting--
- Watercolor?
- Yeah.
- Very nice.
- I have a painting that
I'm gonna give to you
later backstage.
- Thank you.
- I hope I can take a photo
of you with my painting.
- You sure can, thank you.
- My question is, as
artist, what is the best way
to leverage on the visual quality of art
to actually promote my
online courses on YouTube
and to gain more followers
and to give the most value?
- You notice, you know,
I'm glad you said that.
When you give, you have to give.
The second I hear my online courses,
where you and many others,
and I don't know what you're doing,
could get caught,
and when I say could, 99%,
when you know that you're
putting out something for free,
that what you really want
is for them to sign up
for your online course,
you're fucking dead.
(audience chuckling)
Guys, there's a reason you like me more.
(audience laughing)
(Tom chuckles)
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
I'm not trying to funnel
you into anything.
I want nothing from you.
I want you to tell me the story
that young woman just said earlier.
That's what I want.
You know how much better that feels
than signing up another
person for my $6,000 thing?
(audience laughing)
That, bro.
'Cause if you're putting out content,
you have a visual product.
You should be dominating.
The reason you're not dominating
is every time you post,
you hope they go to your fucking course.
Don't do that.
Just put out great content
and a funny thing will happen.
They'll sign up for your fucking course.
(audience chuckling)
- Okay.
- The intent of content is
the variable of success.
Let me say it one more time
for the people in the back.
The intent that you have
when you put something out
is the variable of how well it will do.
- [Audience Member] Amen to that!
- Amen to that.
(audience applauding)
- [Audience Member] Yeah!
- That's how you'll win.
Teach people how to, to help them.
Then you will get karma in return
and you will sign up more people.
Because when you're putting out content
and they can sense what
you're actually doing
is trying to get them into
the funnel to pay you,
you're finished.
That's what everybody's doing.
And yes, there are plenty of
people that are successful.
I know landing page optimization.
I know, I get it, I understand.
I understand funnels.
I understand.
It's a short-term game.
And every day that goes by,
it's losing leverage,
not gaining leverage.
I'm gonna make sure of it.
Got it?
- Yeah.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Hi, Gary.
My name's Fung Ji.
I'm a personal trainer.
I heard your message about being selfless
and still selfish.
- Yes.
- I also heard your message
about producing content daily.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
When we produce content daily
and you were saying to
that Indonesian lady
that you just produce
what you want, right?
You just produce what
the thing is important.
But do we leverage on the
tools available like BuzzSumo
and maybe we want to tell
the customers what they want?
Or do we just go ahead
and produce what we want?
- Both.
- Doesn't matter?
- This is the part people
keep struggling with.
They analyze things at a surface level,
not at a macro level.
When you put out content every single day,
you can do anything.
Guys, my number one successful post
on Instagram in the last three years
was me eating blueberries
a couple weeks ago.
(audience laughing)
That's fucking crazy!
But that meant that you guys
have been getting so
much of one thing from me
that the second I gave you
something else, you liked it.
You can do both.
- Right.
- That's what volume of content allows.
It allows creativity.
It allows you to be selfish and selfless.
- So, do we splice or
be a marketing inside
or just (blows puff of
air) give it up for free?
(Gary blows puff of air)
(audience chuckling)
Okay, thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Gary, how you doing?
I'm Paul Evans.
I've been in recruitment for 20 years.
I've been living here for
10, five years in Hong Kong,
five years here in Singapore and love it.
- [Gary] Understood.
- I worked inside a bank
and I've been recruiting
for investment banks
for that whole time, all here in Asia.
I joined LinkedIn in 2004.
That's the only social media
platform I actually joined.
- Right.
- Sad as it sounds.
I didn't post anything
until two months ago.
I had a cycling accident and
I shot out my collarbone.
- Sorry.
- I had a titanium plate
put in and I did the video straight after
'cause I just felt there was a connection
between people's careers and
some of the observations I had
through the experience of the accident.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- Anyway, so I just put that
out and I got 8,000 hits
and I was shocked.
So, on the bed of the hospital,
after the operation, I made
another video for one minute
and made another connection.
The message was really
people not to beat
themselves up, essentially.
But the one concern I have now
is if that's from January start-up Paul
but actually if I join a corporation,
- Yes.
- I wanna put out content
- in the same manner
- Yes.
- which is, you know,
it's from the heart, it's free,
I'm not looking for any kickback, right?
- [Gary] You don't have to
overthink the politics of it.
- Right, so if you're in a corporation
as perhaps people are here,
how do you manage putting content out
whilst you have a banner or a brand
that you represent in the market
without having to go through
layers of approval every time
before you wanna share
something meaningful
to people in your industry?
- Life is about decisions.
There are many organizations
that you will be able to join
that will not give you
any headaches to do that.
There will be far more
that won't let you do it.
Nobody's forcing you to work anywhere.
If you're deciding that the stability
or the income that you're
getting from that job,
this is, you know,
in America, cannabis industry
is going through a big transition, right?
You can't run ads for cannabis companies
on Facebook and Instagram.
It's against the terms of services
as America figures out its
marijuana/cannabis laws.
I go speak at this event and
all these people come up to me.
They're like, "Facebook's
screwing me, Gary!
"Fuckin' Instagram's fucking me!"
I'm like, "No, it's not.
"They tell you what the rules are.
"You don't like the rules,
you try to start an account,
"they shut you down."
I don't like that companies
act wannabe capitalists
but then treat their
employees like it's communism.
- Right.
- Which is why I don't do it.
My employees can do
whatever the fuck they want.
They can start a VaynerMedia
within the company,
do content, and steal my,
I don't give a shit 'cause I'm not scared.
But the reality is you
have to make a decision.
Are you gonna maximize your salary
and not give a fuck about that rule?
Or are you gonna find a job, right,
that pays you maybe a little bit less
but gives you the freedom
you're looking for?
It's as simple as that.
- Blended and happy, right?
- What's that?
- That's right.
- [Paul] Find the happy medium.
- Here's what I love.
This is why I love Q and A.
When you have a logical conversation,
the great thing is you're in charge.
I understand what you'd like to happen
and I say to you, hey,
are you gonna take this
$237,000-a-year job
that doesn't let you
or do you wanna take this
$150,000-a-year job that does?
I think what's remarkable is
people are starting to realize
this second job is starting to make sense.
And that is not how we
grew up, the last 80 years,
when it was maximize money.
Now, it's maximize
happiness and opportunity.
Because if you take the $150,000
and you do your content,
what you already know,
you've already tasted it,
is you're only three years away
from making $430,000 on your terms.
- [Paul] Right.
Correct.
You're awesome, thank you.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Audience Member] Hi, Gary.
Hi, DRock.
(Gary chuckles)
- He's focused.
- Firstly, I want to start with saying
that you're my inspiration,
you're my role model,
you're my mentor.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for everything that you do.
- I'm one of--
- [Gary] Thank you for the
sneakers you're wearing.
(audience chuckling)
- I'm one of the Indian that
has come especially for you.
I came to know that you
are coming for this event
and I thought this is the
best opportunity I could get
to see you live.
My question to you is,
in an earlier interview of yours,
you had spoken about having
a chip on your shoulder
that pushed you into doing more.
What is that chip and what
if someone doesn't realize
what that chip should be for them?
- [Gary] One more time,
I wanna understand.
I understand the chip on the shoulder.
What are you asking?
(audience chuckling)
- What is that chip for you--
- For me?
- Yeah.
- The chip for me was that
the first 18 years of my life,
the entire world besides my mother
said that I was gonna lose.
I'm 43 years old.
I grew up in an America
where going to a good college
was the only indicator
of you being successful
and I was a D and F student
so every teacher I had and
all my friends' parents
thought that I was the loser
kid in the neighborhood,
and what I thought was
they were the losers.
(audience chuckling)
I was right.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
So, my chip, my chip
was I was an immigrant,
I came to a country, I
didn't speak the language,
you know, I was a terrible student.
Every place in my life
was telling me no, no, no,
except one place, when I sold lemonade,
when I shoveled snow, when
I sold baseball cards.
There was this one place where
there was nobody's judgment.
It was just the market.
Just the market decided.
And that's where I was best, the market.
Not somebody's judgment.
And that was my chip.
- Follow-up question.
What if someone doesn't realize
what that chip is for them?
- Then they won't be able to execute
because if you are not self-aware
about your own feelings,
you're vulnerable.
The question is are you
not willing to look?
A lot of people in this
room aren't willing to look
because it's too painful to
know where it's coming from.
Most people's biggest
problem here is a parent.
That's not fun.
And so, I'm empathetic to that.
- One last thing.
If you could sign my copy
of "Crushing It!" after this
because that book changed my life--
- Well, fuck, let's do it right now.
Changing lives is what I'm here to do.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much.
- We'll get it.
This is some real great
fucking service around here
you guys have.
Thank you.
(audience chuckling)
Go ahead.
- [Audience Member] Hey,
Gary, I'm a big fan.
- Thank you.
- I like your show on YouTube,
especially when you pick up
just like a random phone call from people.
- Yes.
- I see that, you know,
a lot of advice you gave them
is either going over your fear
and also crushing one's ego.
Now, I was a U.S. Marines
before I opened my own business.
What I wanna ask you
is how do you identify
if you are taking action based on egos
when you're kinda like
immersed in that lifestyle
for quite some times?
And if you find that,
how do you destroy that?
You know, what do you do?
- Do you think that's
what's happening with you?
- I think some--
- Let's talk.
- In some cases, I could be because--
- Ego is not confidence.
Ego is insecurity, right?
- Okay.
- When you're scared or
nervous or not confident,
a lot of people have DNA that
makes them overcompensate.
I call it a cactus.
They're a cactus.
They're tough on the outside
but they're soft on the inside.
The reason I keep telling
everybody kindness is a strength
is I'm super nice and
super passive, actually,
like I'm willing to let
people take advantage of me
because I'm strong inside.
So, the question is, you have to just know
if you're nervous, if
you're using fake confidence
to actually hide something
you're concerned about.
Humility is an incredible strength
that many men and many
people never want to show.
Guys, I put out content
more about me passing on Uber and losing
than I do about the things I win on.
Everybody else puts out
content of fake wins.
That's the difference.
You understand?
- Yes.
- This is only something you can answer.
When are you most insecure?
How do you then act when it happens?
And if you front, that's
your defense mechanism
and you need to understand that.
- Yeah, 'cause the way, I mean,
the way I will run my company ideally
since I was brought up in a military,
everybody gotta do a certain way,
if not, they'll get hammered for it.
- The problem is--
- And I know
it's not gonna work.
- It's not gonna work.
It's not gonna work
because they have options.
In the military when you sign up
and your sergeant or general
or whatever the fuck it is
are like fuck and you're like fuck,
you gotta fucking do it.
- Yeah.
- In a business, they're
like, "That's good, I quit."
(audience chuckling)
When you run a company,
you work for everybody,
not they work for you.
- Got it.
- And so, yeah.
There's plenty of things you've
learned that are amazing.
And by the way, for many
people, that system will work.
You just have to know that, as a leader,
there isn't one thing that fits everybody.
So, either you find
people that it works for
or you develop the ability
to manage people differently
than just that way.
That, you decide.
You don't have to do it the
way I'm telling you to do it.
You could just spend all
your time finding people
that like the military way
and they like that vigor.
I believe to scale, you
have to have multiple ways
to address issues, leadership,
things of that nature.
- Got it, thank you.
- You got it, you got it.
(audience applauding)
Hi.
- Hello, Gary.
I'm Barry Wijarut, 32 this year.
I would like to thank you
because I've been following your content
for a long time.
- Thank you.
- And then that has really inspired me
in my entrepreneurship journey.
- Thank you.
- So, for me,
it's that I actually in the
past, I also was one of the guys
that in secondary schools I
was turned down by teachers,
almost thrown out of schools.
And then I bootstrapped myself.
I worked full-time and at the
same time built up my business
so I got a chain of Thai restaurants
and food courts in Singapore.
- Very nice.
- Yeah, so now the question is that
money doesn't really motivates me.
- Me either.
- 'Cause along the way,
I realize that I thought
that I'm after money
but now I'm not really exactly wealthy
but I'm think I'm comfortable.
But money just doesn't motivate me and--
- [Gary] You like the process.
- Yeah, and I feel
along the way I discover
what I truly love is that
every time I face a problems,
ironically I feel a bit happy
because once I overcome that problem,
I get to share with people.
And then I realize that my true desire
is to actually impact entrepreneurships,
to inspire people to continue
to find their purpose,
find their voice in life.
And then now, I'm stopped
because I do have employees
that I'm actually focusing to help them
to bring up to the next level
but at the same time,
there is an inner desire
of me wanting to share this
and I don't know whether
do I need to continue
to build my business
and then share it later
and impact lives later or
do I do it concurrently?
And what are the contents I
should put up to the market?
- Do it now.
- Concurrently.
- All right, okay.
- I'm doing it.
(audience chuckling)
- (chuckles) Yeah.
- Right?
You know, you have permission
'cause you've lived it.
Just like that gentleman
with the awesome yellow,
don't fake what you don't, you know.
Certain things you haven't
gotten to in your career yet.
For example, I've started
sprinkling it a little bit.
I've been talking more about the year,
I've been mentioning lately,
I've only a couple of times,
I don't know if you've heard this
but I'm starting to talk about how I think
you have to love your company at first
but then you have to start
bringing candor and merit,
and I felt that I mismanaged
VaynerMedia one year too late
and I created entitlement and
that was a problem for us.
I needed to wait a couple
years for that era to pass
'cause I didn't wanna talk about something
that people were living in
my company at that moment.
But, you know, you haven't
lived everything yet.
But you have to talk about it when you do.
But you can do it concurrently.
- [Barry] But when it talks about focus
then how do I actually split my time to--
- Whose focus?
Who gets to decide what focus is?
I have a fucking wine
company, a shoe deal,
content, VaynerMedia, a
fucking wine library, Gary Vee,
fucking baseball cards I'm
trying to sell, garage sale.
I'm the least fucking focused
focused fucker you'll ever meet.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Guys, if you're a real entrepreneur,
you kind of can't just do one thing.
(audience member hoots)
That's how we're fucked up.right?
(audience applauding)
Right?
Like, I'm gonna come up
with three business ideas
in the next hour, and I'm
gonna do that every day,
and I'll probably do
two of them in the year
because that's what makes us happy.
You can do both.
- And Gary, one last question
is what kind of content do I do?
Do I do like my restaurant's content?
What kind of contents you--
- Well, if you're trying
to impact and help,
it needs to be more macro.
It can't be literal because most of us
don't own restaurants.
(audience chuckling)
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Barry] Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- Hi, Gary.
I'm Harut, I'm 27.
I'm originally from India.
Been living in Singapore
for the past few years.
First of all, I just wanna say I love you.
- [Gary] (chuckling) Thank
you, I love you, too.
(audience chuckling)
- I have a twofolded question.
I had a stable job.
I let it go a few years ago
and I've been doing things on my own.
I'm full-time trader
and I've set up an education
business around it.
It's going pretty good.
You were talking about
being lonely just now.
Can you talk about that a bit more
especially when it's lonely--
- Are you lonely?
- No, I'm not, but...
(audience chuckling)
I'm getting married in a couple
of months so clearly not.
(Gary chuckles)
(audience laughing)
Yeah, so my question was--
- [Gary] But lonely as an entrepreneur
or doing your own thing
is a very different game
than having somebody in your life.
- Exactly, so that's
what I was getting to.
In terms of talking about being lonely
when you don't kind of get the support
from your family or from
your close people around you,
how do you deal with that and still--
- I deal with it extremely well
because I love sticking it to people
that don't think I've got it.
- [Harut] I mean, even
if it's your spouse,
your parents--
- Especially.
(audience laughing)
I'm being dead serious.
Guys, I get, right?
I understand how potentially
disheartening it is
when your fiancee or parents or things
don't believe in what you're doing.
But it makes it so much more
exciting when you achieve it
because then you get to stick it to them.
(audience chuckling)
- [Harut] Well, I've never
really thought it that way but--
- Well, this is the way
(audience laughing)
to think about it.
- [Harut] Okay, uh...
- But you have to understand.
Nobody understands an entrepreneur
if they're not an entrepreneur
'cause they want safe.
But for you, you'd be unhappy being safe.
You just lived it.
- Yes.
- So, I have empathy for her.
But you're not capable of
living your life any other way.
So, here's the best part of the argument,
the debate, the issue.
Somebody's gonna be right.
- Yes.
- Either you're gonna go
and execute and provide for
your family as an entrepreneur
and then you get to say to her, "See?"
Or you're gonna fail and not provide
and have to go get a job
and then she gets to say, "See."
(audience laughing)
- Right, when you put it--
- That's the only two options.
Either your parents are
right or you're right.
Either your husband is
Either the commenters in
your section are right
or you're right.
I spend no time on the
cheering or the boos.
I spend on executing so
that when it goes to 000,
I can say I was right.
- (hoots) Yes!
(audience applauding)
- And just slightly adding on to that,
I know you've had previous videos
where you talked about
handling hate on social media,
kind of acknowledge them and
you start a conversation,
bring the
- I think, yeah, keep going.
- positivity into it.
But how do you, like, do you
address every one of them?
Because at end of the day,
it still takes up your time.
- Yeah, I can't address
all of my hate anymore.
(audience chuckling)
But I think that too many people,
when somebody says something
they don't like to hear,
dismiss it as hate and a troll.
I read it and question it
and then decide is there any merit to it.
And the reason I've been able to evolve
is because I don't just default
if somebody disagrees
with me or makes fun of me
that they're wrong.
I try to be thoughtful
about what are they doing.
Nine out of 10 times, it's
'cause they're in a bad place
and they're just trying to drag me down.
But occasionally, there's a point there
that I kind of fester in
and start subconsciously
adjusting what I'm doing.
Feedback is important.
- Perfect, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
- [Reagan] Hi, Gary.
- One more?
Guys, I only have time
for one more question.
I apologize.
- Hi, Gary.
My name is Reagan.
Basically, I wanna ask, as an entrepreneur
where you're hustling every single day,
- Yes.
- and sometimes, you know,
we are like workaholics,
we don't even know when time pass by,
but sometimes how do you actually account
for how much you have actually done?
Or how do you account how
productive you have been
as an entrepreneur?
For example, I could write one article
and I could be very productive.
I could write three articles
but I'm not productive.
So, how do you actually account
of how much work I have done
as an entrepreneur?
- It sounds like you're
doing what we all do
which is it sounds like you're being
your own judge and jury.
- [Reagan] Right.
- So, I think you just
need to love yourself more.
- Right.
(audience laughing)
- I'm being serious.
It's a very interesting insight.
When you were asking the question,
I think every day, I'm phenomenal.
I'm being dead serious.
Because I'm trying as hard as I can,
I have very good intent,
I'm really trying,
and if today was a less productive day
'cause I was tired or a
meeting didn't go well
or who knows why,
I'm just not capable of
beating myself up today.
I look at it over the course of time.
I mean, you know, you get to
be the judge and the jury.
- Right, right.
One more question, it's
actually about millennials.
A lot of times, people see
that, oh, this guy's too young
or for me, as a Singaporean,
it's like, you haven't go army,
why should I listen to you?
And you also say about
being authentic, right?
But I'm being authentic
and sometimes people
just don't believe of let's
say my experience or portfolio.
- That was my whole life from 20 to 40.
- Right.
(audience chuckling)
Right.
Basically, just be authentic
and just share with the world
what you just really want to share.
- What's the alternative?
Make shit up?
(audience laughing)
- [Reagan] (chuckles) Right.
- You know what I mean?
- Yes.
- Look.
(audience applauding)
Everything that you now know me for
is nothing I was saying and doing
was accepted when I was doing it.
Guys, I launched an
e-commerce business in 1996.
People thought the internet was a fad.
Email, Google AdWords.
I started one of the
first YouTube shows ever.
I invested in Facebook and Twitter
before anybody ever heard of it.
Tumblr, Uber, everything.
I started having a man
follow me with a camera
three years ago.
People thought that,
everything I do, you're gonna be the,
you can't be upset and
try to convince people
who are gonna judge you on age.
You just need to move
on to the next person
and figure out which one's
not gonna judge you on age.
And by the way, youngsters, take it from,
who's over 40 here?
Raise your hands.
Raise it high.
Us with our hands up, we lived in a world
where 100% of 20-year-olds
and 25-year-olds
were not listened to.
Because technology became big,
you guys are way more
respected than we were at 25.
You're over-respected.
(audience chuckling)
I mean it.
People think, oh, you're a
kid, you understand technology.
No, you don't.
So, the reality is, you've
heard a lot of this today.
Don't be in the convincing business.
Go to who's already convinced.
- All right.
- You know what I mean?
- Thank you so much.
- You got it.
- [Man In Black Shirt] One question, Gary.
- Hi, Gary, last question?
- Yes.
- Last question?
- Yep.
- Hi, I'm Jillian and
I've been following you
for the last 1 1/2 years.
You're the only one with the
push notifications turned on
on my Instagram.
- Thank you.
- (chuckles) And I love
how you're pounding
the same messages every day.
It's very consistent and it's very easy
to remember and follow.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- But also, you know, I
wanted to bring to a point.
How do you, you talked about framing
contextual creative at scale.
- Yes.
- How do you do that,
or do you have a structure?
How do you frame it?
I understand, you also
mentioned to one of the ladies,
Marie or something,
that Q and A is one of
the innovative ways,
but what are the other ways,
aside from the three
different types of media?
- What I mean by that in
its most important form
is when you're talking to somebody,
you need to relate to them.
So, if you're making a piece of content
to 18- to 20-year-olds,
- I'm the crazy guy that...
- you need to use adjectives
and cultural references
to an 18- to 20-year-old.
- Does that include cursing?
- You know what I mean?
I mean, that's the point.
The point is you need to make
it contextual to the audience.
When I speak here,
there's a lot of things
that I didn't say today
that I would've definitely
said if I was in New York
because it would've made
sense to New Yorkers
but wouldn't have made sense here.
On YouTube, I can make a 41-minute video.
On Instagram, it was a minute.
Then IGTV came, and now it can be 41.
So, you have to respect the platform
but first you have to respect
who you're trying to reach.
- Okay.
- So, when I say contextual
at scale, it's what audience
are you trying to reach
and then do you use what
slang, what references.
Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- Too many people are
trying to reach everybody.
Which means you're not reaching anybody.
It's vanilla.
You understand?
So, again, this is the theme of this talk.
When you make so much content,
when I make a video that says,
"50 years," "for the next
50 years," "50-year-olds,"
"you've got 50 more years to live,"
and the whole video is, "Hey, are you 50?
"Are you out of your mind?
"You're still young, let's
go, let me tell you why.
"You're gonna live longer
which means you're only halfway
"but you grew up in an
era where 50 was old
"when we were kids," and da da da.
No 21-year-old is watching that video.
Maybe they watch it
quickly 'cause they like me
and they pass it to their parent.
When I make a video that
says, "Fuck your parents!"
(audience laughing)
the kids love that,
the parents are DMing me
like, "You motherfucker."
I'm like, "Fuck you!"
(Jillian laughs)
You know, so that's what I mean.
- [Jillian] Okay, thank you for coming
to my home country, Singapore.
- Thank you.
- What contextual creative
would you do for this?
What kinda slangs do you have
for our Singaporean market?
- The number one thing that I think about
for this market and this region
is the dynamic of parents'
pressure on children.
- [Jillian] Mm.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- It is my number one.
It is my number one.
It is a problem in America
but it is absolutely more
prevalent in Asian countries
where parents think kids' success
is an indicator on them
and they treat their
children like products,
not like children.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- Thank you for that.
I agree with you.
I actually quit my corporate job
to train professionally as an athlete.
So, (chuckling) defy my
parents' notion of the ambition
and just went for what I love.
- I love it.
- Thank you.
- Singapore, thank you.
(audience applauding)
I'm sorry.
- All right.
- Sign?